format carte bancaire et puces
électroniques voici à quoi ressemble la
nouvelle carte d'identité française
au recto votre photo vos nom et prénom
date de naissance nationalité sexe ou
encore date de délivrance de la carte
bref les informations de base la grande
nouveauté se situe au verso de la carte
c'est là que se trouve la puce
électronique ainsi qu un qr code
ce document répond désormais non
seulement aux normes européennes car le
2 août était la date butoir fixée par
bruxelles pour la modernisation des
titres d'identité mais il est aussi plus
sécurisé que l'ancien en matière de
fraude et d'usurpation d'identité c'est
en tout cas ce qu'explique le ministère
de l'intérieur en 2019 la fraude à
l'identité a représenté près de 45000
plaintes 1 19% du total des infractions
relevées sur l'année la nouvelle carte
d'identité sera plus sécurisé et plus
pratique et verra son design modernisé
les pouvoirs publics entendent ainsi
lutter toujours plus efficacement contre
le phénomène de la fraude à l'identité
cette volonté de modernisation rejoint
l'application d'un règlement du
parlement européen et du conseil de
l'union européenne qui oblige les états
membres à mettre en circulation de
nouvelles cartes d'identité conforme aux
dispositions de ce règlement au plus
tard le 2 août 2021
la puce électronique contient tous les
éléments inscrit sur la carte incluant
votre photo mais également vos
empreintes digitales même chose pour le
qr code qui rassemble toutes ces
informations
il s'agit d'un cachet électronique
visible signé par l'état une sorte de
signature numérique qui garantit que les
données n'ont pas été modifiées côté
sécurité le ministère de l'intérieur
rappelle que les données biométriques
contenues dans la puce sont hautement
sécurisés et l'accès à ces données je
cite spécifiquement encadré pour autant
cette nouvelle carte ne constitue pas ce
que l'on appelle une identité numérique
régaliennes ce que pointe du doigt ses
détracteurs non seulement parce qu'elle
ne permet pas d'accéder à des services
étatiques mais aussi parce qu'en terme
de sécurité selon eux il n'y a pas
vraiment de garantie une seule
difficulté c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'identité numérique tels régaliennes et
que la france a fait un choix choix
d'ailleurs assez étonnant c'est de celui
de
d'utiliser des identités numériques
privé alors ça va être la poste ça va
être la caf
ça va être un certain nombre
d'organismes qui vont pouvoir utiliser
donc les l'identité numérique pour vous
permettre d'utiliser leurs services
alors que au niveau européen l'idée
était quand même plutôt d'avoir une
carte d'identité numérique qui vous
permet d'accéder justement être
indifférent services étatiques et
européens pour l'espère peut-être dans
un deuxième temps et de manière ultra
sécurisé l avantage que l'état supervise
le tout c'est que on est véritablement
des garanties par rapport à la sécurité
être comme ça à la merci d'un opérateur
privé ne me semble pas tout à fait tout
à fait cohérent d'autant plus qu'il ya
un problème de données personnelles et
donc leur l'occurrence des données
biométriques qui sont inclus dans la
carte la carte d'identité et ses données
biométriques peuvent être passés à
éventuellement des tiers qui n'ont
absolument pas en connaître donc une
certaine crainte par rapport justement à
la à la fiabilité des systèmes qui sont
mis en place
les détracteurs de cette nouvelle carte
d'identité au doute donc que leurs
données soient utilisées au delà de leur
finalité initiale
toujours est il qu'à partir de ce 2 août
donc toute personne qui souhaite
renouveler ou demandé sa carte
d'identité recevra ce nouveau format
valable dix ans